l'ordre du jour donc appelle les
questions orales et la première question
numéro 157 de Monsieur André triard à
Madame la Ministre chargé des personnes
handicapées et de la lutte contre
l'exclusion monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaite évoquer avec vous la situation
des parents d'enfants en situation de
handicap parents qui leur vie durant
vont prendre en charge le enfant en
qualité d'aidant familial madame la
ministre vous le savez bien la survenue
du ap chez un membre de la famille
modifie les repères et tous les projets
familiaux au-delà du traumatisme c'est
souvent un vrai bouleversement que donne
lieu dans l'urgence l'adaptation le
réaménagement familial professionnel et
relationnel avec le risque de placer
dans une situation de véritable
isolement celui des parents auquel
incombera la situation d'aident familial
le plus souvent sa mère sur le plan
professionnel celle-ci est fréquemment
contrainte d'arrêter temporairement ou
définitivement son activité il s'ensuit
une perte de revenu pouvant conduire la
précarisation la vie conjugale du couple
est souvent mise entre parenthèses
chacun vivant les preuve de manière
différente desménages
éclate la relation avec les autres
enfants est incestablement
transformé très rapidement la réalité
fait apparaître une fatigue physique et
morale tant pour les dents que pour
l'ensemble de la famille si des progrès
ont été accomplis au cours des dernières
années pour prendre en compte cette
situation très particulière et autant
que possible faciliter matériellement
certains aspects de leur vie quotidienne
il reste que son dédommagement inférieur
à l'indemnité ou au salaire d'un
professionnel ne donne accès ni au
droits sociaux ni au droits à la
retraite et pourtant cette rétribution
est
imposable faut-il rappeler que la
journée de travail dans ce cas fait 24
heures et qu'elle n'a pas de vacances
madame la ministre j'ai deux questions à
vous poser l'une de fond concerne les
intentions concrètes de votre
gouvernement s'agissant de ce problème
précis de la connaissance des droits
pour les familles et les proches qui
apportent une aide régulière à leur
enfant ou à tout autre membre de la
famille je veux parler de l'amélioration
du droit à compensation et des
prestations familiales mais au droit au
répis au soutien personnalisé à la
formation des mesures liées à la vie
professionnelle des aides de Retour à
l'Emploi et de la mise en place
d'équivalence professionnelle l'autre
question est plutôt une suggestion celle
consistant à attribuer une distinction
comparable à à celle de la médaille de
la famille qui récompense aujourd'hui
les parents ayant élevé quatre enfants
ou plus
l'idée serait de témoigner à ses parents
dont la vie a été mise entre parenthèses
la reconnaissance qu'il mérite ainsi
qu'à saluer l'abnégation et le
dévouement dont ils font
preuve reprenant récemment la jeunesse
de cette médaille créée en 1920 j'ai pu
constater que contrairement à une idée
répandu elle n'avait pas de Visé
nataliste mais que le but alors
poursuivi était de récompenser des
parents ayant élevé dignement leurs
enfants il me semble que cette
proposition s'inscrit parfaitement dans
cette philosophie je vous remercie merci
mon cher collègue la parole est à Madame
Marie Arlette Carlotti minist chargée
des personnes handicapées de la lutte
contre l'exclusion vous avez la parole
madame monie président messieurs les
sénateur monsieur le sénateur André
triard les aidants familiaux jouent un
rôle essentiel et de plus en plus
reconnu en France ce sont 8 millions de
personnes qui s'occupent directement de
leurs proches malades ou en perte
d'autonomie et qui leur apporte un
soutien moral et un soutien financier
les pouvoirs publics ont pleinement
conscience du rôle essentiel joué par
ces familiaux dans le soutien à domicile
de leurs proches en perte d'autonomie
handicapé ou malade et en ce qui me
concerne je suis particulièrement
attentive à la situation extrêmement
difficile vous l' voquz monsieur le
sénateur des parents d'enfants
handicapés qui tout au long de leur vie
prennent en charge leurs enfants il
existe déjà un ensemble de mesures
visant à soutenir les aidants familiaux
les congés familiaux sont là pour les
aider à concilier leur vie
professionnelle et leur rôle auprès de
leurs enfants laallocation d' education
de l'enfant handicapé la prestation de
compensation du handicap et la location
personnalisée d'autonomie soutiennent
financièrement l'aide qu'ils apportent à
leurs enfants enfin le développement de
la formation et de l'accompagnement et
du répis permet de les aider à faire
face et à regarder un peu plus
sereinement quand c'est possible vers
l'avenir d'année en année on voit donc
se multiplier les initiatives favorisant
le soutien et le répit apportés aux
aidanss de la part de multiples acteurs
les asso ition les collectivités
territoriales les caises de retraite de
base et complémentaires les centres
locaux d'information et de coordination
consultations mémoire les fondations et
cetera la Caisse nationale de solidarité
pour l'autonomie ainsi que les agences
régionales de santé peuvent cofinancer
des actions de formation et de soutien
destiné à tous les aidants de personnes
handicapées ou de personnes âgées qui en
ont besoin le président de la République
s'est engagé à développer des actions de
formation et des structures permettant
aux aidans d'avoir des temps de répis et
ce sera travaillé dans le cadre du
projet de loi que ma collègue Michel de
Launet prépare en ce moment activement
je seraiis à ses côté sur ce point le
gouvernement a par ailleurs soumis aux
partenaires sociaux la proposition
d'assouplir le congé de soutien familial
afin qu'il soit plus facile d'y recourir
alors l'attribution d'une distinction
honorifique spécifique maintenant aux
aidentss familiaux serait-elle la forme
adéquate de reconnaissance nationale de
leur dév
parmi les distinctions honorifiques la
médaille de la famille est décernée aux
personnes qui élèvent ou qui ont élev
dignement par leur soins attentifs et
leur dévouement de nombreux enfants elle
rend ainsi hommage à leur mérite et
témoigne de la reconnaissance de la
Nation les critères d'attribution de la
médaille de la famille sont avant tout
fondés sur le nombre d'enfants élevés et
sur les efforts consentis pour les
élever dans les meilleures conditions
matérielles et morales le dévouement et
les soins apporté par les parents aidans
familiaux à leurs enfants en situation
de handicap relève donc de cette logique
bien que le critère du nombre d'enfants
élevés puisse limiter leur accès à cette
distinction le Centre d'analyse
stratégique dans sa note d'analyse de
septembre a d'ailleurs relevé que la
médaille de la famille reste dans notre
pays l'apanage des pères et des mères de
familles nombreuses alors que d'autres
valeurs sont mises à l'honneur dans
d'autres pays comme la mise en œuvre
d'une véritable égalité parentale c'est
pourquoi Monsieur le Sénateur je puis
vous assurer que la question de la
reconnaissance des mérites des familles
ayant élevé un enfant handicapé aura
toute sa place dans la réflexion au
sujet des récompenses honorifiques pour
les familles que compte engager très
prochainement la ministre déléguée à la
famille monsieur le sénateur je soutiens
donc votre
suggestion merci madame la ministre
monsieur triard merci merci madame la
ministre je vous remercie pour cette
réponse je vous rappelle que interrogé
en novembre dernier par l'unapeille sur
les priorité de la politique du handicap
à mener pour l'année et les années à
venir vous avez répondu que beaucoup de
choses ont été fait ce que vous avez
développé tout à l'heure sur le handicap
et que vous souhaitiez vous inscrire
dans la continuité de cet engagement
porté principalement par les familles
nous sommes bien d'accord sur ce point
je ne peux que vous féliciter sur ce
parti prix je vous venez de rappeler les
projets du
gouvernement je reste un peu sur ma fin
mais nous verrons dans le prochain texte
de loi je vous remercie aussi pour
l'accueil que vous avez réservé euh à
cette proposition à cette idée euh cette
proposition bien modeste d'une
distinction aux parents de personnes
handicapées je pense qu'elle trouvera
bien sa place dans le texte annoncé par
le gouvernement au printemps prochain
sur la famille et qu'elle vaudra bien
certaines dispositions qui nont rien à
faire merci